E
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT, KIM KARDASHIAN HAS
BIG NEWS.
>> KIM KARDASHIAN IS EXPANDING
YOUR BRAND ONCE AGAIN.
SHE IS STARTING A PRIVATE EQUITY
FIRM WITH JAY SAMMONS, A 16 YEAR
VETERAN OF THE CARLYLE GROUP AND
PRINCE WILLIAM AND HARRY, THE
REAL DRAMA CONTINUES.
>> THE BODY LANGUAGE, THE
PICTURES SAID A THOUSAND WORDS.
THE BODY LANGUAGE WAS STRAINED.
>> Laura: AND TOM AND GISELE.
TROUBLE IN PARADISE?
>> THE REPORTEDLY HITTING A
ROUGH PATCH IN THEIR MARRIAGE.
THE EEL IS TROUBLE STARTED WHEN
TOM RETURNED TO THE NFL.
>> Laura: AND LIZZO FINALLY
GETS RECOGNIZED WITH THE BIGAMY.
>> Laura: WHEN I WAS A LITTLE
GIRL, ALL I WANTED TO SEE WAS ME
IN THE MEDIA.
SOMEONE WHO SAT LIKE ME.
MAKE SOME NOISE FOR MY BIG GIRL
>> Secretary Psaki:
>> Laura: GOD BLESS.
THIS IS WHAT THE DOMINANT DUMB
DOWN, TICK-TOCK CULTURE LIKES US
TO FOCUS ON.
ALL OF IT'S A DISTRACTION.
NONE OF IT MATTERS TO DAILY
LIFE.
BUT YOU KNOW IT DOES MATTER?
OUR GOVERNMENT.
OUR $24 TRILLION ECONOMY?
IT'S BEING MANAGED BY
DUNDERHEADS.
>> WITH THIS LAW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ONE AND SPECIAL INTERESTS
LOST.
SAY IT AGAIN: THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ONE AND SPECIAL INTERESTS
LOST.
LOWER HEALTH INSURANCE COSTS.
LOWER ENERGY COSTS FOR MILLIONS
OF FAMILIES.
I WANT TO TAKE THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE ACTION NEVER EVER
EVER TO CONFRONT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AND INCREASE OUR ENERGY
SECURITY, EVER IN THE WHOLE
WORLD.
AND THAT'S NOT HYPERBOLE, AND
ITS FACT.
>> Laura: IN THE WHOLE WORLD.
DIMWITS AT
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE WERE
ACTUALLY OUT CELEBRATING TODAY.
TALK ABOUT DYSFUNCTIONAL.
THEY SCHEDULED THIS EVENT IN THE
EXPECTATION THAT THEY WERE TO
GET REALLY GOOD NEWS ON
INFLATION THIS MORNING.
BUT INSTEAD THEY GOT VERY
TERRIBLE NEWS ABOUT INFLATION.
THE MARKET DROPPED 1200 POINTS,
THE DOW WAS OFF ALMOST 4%.
>> FOR A DAY THAT IS PLANNED FOR
WEEKS TO BE A CELEBRATION OF A
CORNERSTONE LEGISLATIVE
ACHIEVEMENT, THE SPLIT SCREEN OF
THAT CPI REPORT ON THE MARKET
REACTION TO IT WAS CERTAINLY NOT
IDEAL FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> THE S&P 500 IS DOWN 4.2%.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THIS KIND OF A
BIG DROP IN MORE THAN TWO YEARS.
>> Laura: THIS IS
CATASTROPHIC.
POLITICIANS LIE, MY FRIENDS.
USE AND HOW THOSE NUMBERS.
THE MEDIA OUTLETS THEY LIE.
BUT THE NUMBERS DO NOT LIE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT RECENT
HISTORY.
REAL WORLD HOUSEHOLD INCOME ROSE
FROM $66,000 IN 2016 TO
7,102,020.
THAT'S AN INCREASE OF 6.8% IN
ONLY FOUR EUROS.
THAT WAS STUFF DESPITE DESPITE
THE EFFECTS OF COVID.
BUT NOW?
BY SPENDING TRILLIONS ON
NONSENSE PROGRAMS AND PRINTING
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
DEMOCRATS AND JOE BIDEN ARE
ROBBING YOU BLIND.
A NEW REPORT CAME UP FROM THE
CENSUS BUREAU TODAY SAYING THAT
REAL MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME
FELL FROM 7,102,020 TO 70,000 IN
2021.
ANOTHER WORD THE U.S. ECONOMY
UNDER TRUMP, WHEN WE WERE SHOT
DOWN FROM COVID, GENERATED
BETTER RESULTS FOR THE AVERAGE
PERSON THAN THE U.S. ECONOMY
UNDER BIDEN, WHEN WE HAD A
VACCINE IN THE COUNTRY SHOULD
HAVE TOTALLY REOPENED.
AND THEN GO BACK TO 2019.
THESE NUMBERS ARE IMPORTANT.
THE LAST YEAR BEFORE COVID.
MEDIUM INCOME WAS $72,808.
SO IN 2021, THE MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD
INCOME WAS $2,024 LOWER THAN IT
WAS IN 2019.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
NOW THESE FIGURES SHOW WHERE
TRUMP IS STILL POPULAR.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
AND WHY POPULIST POLICIES WORK
BY PUTTING MONEY IN THE POCKET
OF AVERAGE PEOPLE.
NOT TO PUT THIS ON PROSPECTIVE,
PEOPLE SAW MUCH BIGGER GAINS
UNDER TRUMP IN FOUR YEARS FROM
2016 TO 2020, EVEN WITH COVID,
THEN THEY SIGNED 16 YEARS OF
GEORGE W BUSH AND OBAMA.
AGAIN, FACTS ARE STUBBORN
THINGS.
AND OF COURSE UNDER BIDEN,
THERE'S ALSO THE PROBLEM OF
INFLATION DESTROYING SAVINGS
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THIS, WE PAY
THE BILLS, HIGH PRICES ARE
CAUSING AVERAGE AMERICAN
FAMILIES TO SPEND $460 MORE PER
MONTH THIS YEAR THAN THEY DID A
YEAR AGO.
AND BY THE WAY, WHEN THESE FACTS
COLLIDE, WITH A DAY OF
CELEBRATION OF THE WHITE HOUSE,
OUT OF THEY END UP SPINNING IT?
>> OVERALL, OUR PRICES HAVE
ESSENTIALLY BEEN FLAT IN THE
COUNTRY THESE LAST TWO MONTHS.
THAT'S WELCOME NEWS FOR AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
THIS MONTH, WE SAW SOME WELCOME
MODERATION IN THE PRICE
INCREASES FOR FOOD AT THE
GROCERY STORE.
IT'S MODERATING IN REAL WAGES
ARE GOING UP AGAIN FOR THE
SECOND MONTH IN A ROW.
>> Laura: SHE IS READING THE
WHOLE THING.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
PRICES ARE MODERATING?
IS THAT WHAT SHE SAID.
MOVE OVER BAGHDAD BOB, YOU'VE
GOT COMPETITION.
>> EVERYTHING IS GOTTEN SO MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE.
>> PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE AND
GAS IN THE TANK HAVE BEEN
CAUSING STRESS ON THE
POCKETBOOK.
>> MY KIDS ARE THE ONE
STRUGGLING.
>> GROCERIES, FOOD, GAS, ALL OF
IT IS REALLY HARD FOR THEM IF
YOU'RE MAKING VERY LITTLE MONEY.
ALL YOUR PAYCHECK GOES FOR THOSE
ESSENTIALS.
>> MY BILLS OF, 60%.
>> MY HAVE TO DO THAT IF IT
CONTINUES LIKE THIS.
I WENT BACK TO WORK FULL-TIME ON
A ONE-YEAR CONTRACT TO
SUPPLEMENT HER INCOME.
>> I'M WORKING MORE JOBS THAT I
WANT TO, BUT I JUST PLAIN DON'T
WANT TO WORK ANYMORE.
I WANT TO RETIRE AND THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING EITHER.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY THAT WAS
OUR INTERN WHO DID BETTER
REPORTING ON THAT TOPIC THAN
ANYONE AT THE OTHER NETWORKS
COMBINED.
THE ONLY THING BY THE WAY THAT
MADE SENSE TODAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, OR MAYBE JAMES
TAYLOR'S LYRICS.
>> ♪ ♪
MY BODY IS ACHING.
MY TIME IS AT HAND.
I WON'T MAKE IT ANY OTHER WAY.
♪ ♪
>> I HAVE SEEN FIRE AND I HAVE
SEEN RAIN.
>> Laura: IT'S ALL RAIN AT THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE.
TO THESE PEOPLE NOT KNOW THAT
THIS IS A SONG ABOUT SUICIDE?
IF HE HAD SUNG THAT ON THE ROOF,
I MIGHT'VE JUMPED AFTER HEARING
THIS BUNCH.
>> THE SOUL OF AMERICA IS RIGHT,
AND THE PROMISE OF AMERICA IS
REAL.
IT IS REAL.
>> TODAY WERE GATHERED TO
CELEBRATE ANOTHER HISTORIC STEP
FORWARD FOR OUR NATION.
>> FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART,
I WANT TO THANK EVERY ONE OF MY
SENATE DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES WHO
MADE THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT
HAPPEN.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR
UNIFYING AND INSPIRING A VISION
OF A STRONGER, FAIRER, SAFER
FUTURE FOR ALL, FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
YOUR EXTRAORDINARY LEADERSHIP
HAS MADE THIS GLORIOUS DAY
POSSIBLE.
THAT'S AN APPLAUSE LINE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
LET THEM ONLY DESIGNER
ICE CREAM.
AFTER DINNER AT THE FRENCH
LAUNDRY, NANCY.
BUT THEY KNOW THERE WERE A THAN
THEY WERE UNDER TRUMP.
THIS IS WHY AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN
ARE STARTING TO TURN AWAY FROM
THE DEMOCRATS.
IT'S WHY HISPANICS ARE REJECTING
BIDEN AND HIS BATTALION OF
BUFFOONS.
AND IT'S WHY YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
JUST DISGUSTED.
ANYWAY YOU SEE THE MEDIA IS
TRYING TO DISTRACT US.
THEY CALL AND TALK ABOUT JANUARF
TRYING TO AVOID THE OBVIOUS.
THE OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE IS
THAT POPULISM MAKES THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN RICHER WELL
ESTABLISHMENT POLICIES MADE THEM
POOR.
IN THE MEDIA'S GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO TO AVOID
REPORTING ON THE FACTS WE
BROUGHT YOU.
BECAUSE THE BRUTAL TRUTH, WHILE
IT'S UGLY HERE, IS EMPOWERING.
SO STAY FOCUSED ON THE TRUTH
WHEN YOU GO TO VOTE.
AND TAKE